around five and a half million EU
citizens in their early 20s are without
jobs education or training experts are
saying this is an untenable situation
and it may even get worse although
labour markets have improved slightly in
most EU countries in recent years this
hasn't made life better for Europe's
young people while retirement benefits
and pensions remain stable are only
shrunk slightly in the years of economic
crisis young Europeans find themselves
poorer and that generation gap is
growing
the share of youth at risk of poverty or
social exclusion has increased from
twenty six percent in 2007 to nearly
twenty eight percent in contrast the
corresponding share of the retirement
age population in the EU has shrunk from
24 to just under eighteen percent and
europe-wide trends are set to reinforce
this development investment in education
and research is drying up growing public
debt is weighing heavily on the
shoulders of the young and an aging
population is straining social security
systems if this course is left on
reversed observers warn of a lost
generation